hi everybody I'm really excited to be
here I'm really honored to be speaking
with you today especially because I'm a
relative newcomer to this space of sort
of data science and scientific computing
I'm actually I'm a social scientist and
ethnographer and I spent these of my
dissertation and master's thesis work
studying Wikipedia and community
dynamics and issues with that I'm now at
the berkeley institute for data science
i joined in january where i'm studying
you know how computation is changing the
way that we produce knowledge and so one
of the things that the more I've been in
this sort of new world the more I'm
realizing that there's so many parallels
between the kinds of things that I was
observing and seeing in Wikipedia and
the kind of things that I see in this
space as well and so my hope for this
talk is that something I mentioned sort
of resonates with something that you've
experienced in sort of your sort of work
or the projects that you're a part of or
maybe are a maintainer of and that you
sort of al-saleem I might be interested
in coming to talk with me about how sort
of issues around community
sustainability are playing out so just
as I want to give some you know
resources and references just to sort of
begin because if not I'm going to sort
of forget these also these slides are as
i said before up on github as well so
you can get that the Wikipedia research
portal there so there's a whole bunch of
research that takes place in around
wikipedia I looked through my citation
manager and I had about 400 papers in my
database of Wikipedia research there's a
whole lot there's a newsletter a mailing
list data and code resources ongoing
research projects and more that you can
get information on and also for there's
an evaluation portal that the wikimedia
foundation runs for a lot of initiatives
that they do so if you're interested in
how maybe even learning some things
about how they evaluate measures of
success in their initiatives you might
want to take a look at that sort of
stuff as well and also wiki lid is a
nice set of a sort of online
bibliography for Wikipedia research as
well so just an itinerary where I'm
going today first of all i'm going to
introduce something that's known as the
oh [ __ ] graph and you can actually
google this you google wikipedia oh [ __ ]
graph this is but that's the first
result that comes up it's sort of
something about communion dinamics that
raised a particular flag I'm going to
segue into the history of the Wikipedia
community in relation to that talk about
issues around newcomer socialization and
governance
moving on to issues of diversity
inclusion and representation and finally
sort of talk about some initiatives that
are ongoing and some future steps so
this is not the oh [ __ ] graph yet this
is but this is a graph of the number of
active Wikipedia editors per month so in
blue this is five edits in green this is
over a hundred of it so peripheral
contributors on the top and has sort of
highly active contributors on the bottom
we can grab this logarithmic lee as well
and what we can see is that wikipedia
went through some substantial
exponential growth a few years after it
was founded in 2001 I'm you start to
have a point where Wikipedia was going
from 100 highly active contributors in
2003 to a thousand in 2005 to about
5,000 in 2007 and it has just erupt and
then it started to peak as well and I
speak closer okay oh sorry about that I
can hear that resonate now and so we go
back to this and then the disk graph
actually was not first plotted until
around two thousand eight whenever
things were going down as well and we're
sort of asking the question why are the
number of active contributors to
Wikipedia going down both sort of more
casual contributors as well as long term
contributors and the ohshit graph is
what happens when you plot the average
retention or survival of an hour of an
editor and so we can see you know in
2003 2004-2005 even some 2006 it the
likelihood that someone who joins
Wikipedia and creates even a user page
for themselves and makes a contribution
is going to stick around one to two
years later goes down dramatically it
goes from about fifty to seventy-five
percent of people who stay want who stay
down to at the end of two thousand at
the end of 2011 it was at an all-time
low of less than ten percent of people
that that were retained and we were and
so the reasons why this happened and so
the initiatives that that took place in
response to it is going to be the topic
of this talk and so to give you some
context about about this problem so
wikipedias community history I just want
to sort of also sort of reference a
couple of books that have been written
not not necessarily on this particular
dynamic but a lot of things that can
give you some good background and con
text for this thing's like the Wikipedia
revolution good faith collaboration
Wikipedia in the politics of openness
and and common knowledge these are for
sort of really sort of great texts that
have come out do if you're interested in
learning more about the history of the
Wikipedia community but what I'm going
to talk to you today is sort of start
off in the early days of Wikipedia this
is a screenshot from december 2001 about
11 months after the project was founded
and you know it could be from 1996 from
all we know based on the aesthetics you
know and back then wikipedia was really
the sort of ragtag group as i said as i
showed with the grass before you've got
less than like a hundred sort of highly
active contributors doing it a whole
bunch of people who were more casual
cobb you know sticking around but
they've already got at the end of their
first year nineteen thousand articles as
well and their goal they said if they
hit a hundred thousand and there's two
sort of phrases that really capture the
spirit of what the community was like
and what governance was like back then
and it's from their rules page which is
called rules to consider not rules to
enforce just rules to consider things to
think about and the first one if i
cropped out some of the explanatory text
is ignore all rules if the rules make
you nervous and depressed and not
desirous of participating in the wiki
that ignore them entirely and go about
your business now to put a more
sociological gloss on this what this
sort of effectively means is that we
govern our community by loose norms that
we talk about and we evaluate according
to a consensus on a case-by-case basis
so rules to consider was a page in which
people sort of came and they talked
about some things that they thought were
going on in their project some things
that they thought they should do and not
do but it wasn't ever something that you
would hit someone else over the head
with and tell them that they were doing
a bad job it was instead something you
just sort of really a community space to
talk about what you thought Wikipedia
was and ought to be now 2004 2006 the
wicked so by 2000 for the community is
sort of growing steadily and it's sort
of getting to a point where you know
it's got more and more articles and it
starts to face a whole bunch of external
factors that IH would be really to the
rise of a lot of changes in community
dynamics really wikipedia gets popular
wikipedia starts getting ranked higher
and google results there's major mass
media coverage of wikipedia in places
like the new york times and the BBC
previously Wikipedia got covered in
places like slashdot and we're sort of
people from those sort of communities
would sort of comment and sort of really
influence the first generation of
Wikipedians but then there was a whole
new sort of set of people who were you
know who got there from different places
and then it starts to be major concern
that takes place about Wikipedia is
accuracy and you have three sort of
major events that happen one is the
study that's commissioned by the journal
nature which is a rare thing to actually
have that happen to compare the accuracy
of Wikipedia Encyclopedia Britannica and
they find that for you know on a couple
science articles about a dozen or so
science science articles was the scope
of the study wikipedia and Britannica
are roughly equivalent they have about
the same number of errors this gets
widely misreported as Wikipedia in all
cases is just as accurate as Britannica
in all cases becomes a new story in it
of itself the second punch though the
counter punch though was the
siegenthaler incident that happens a few
months later where John siegenthaler who
is the editor-in-chief of the USA Today
finds out that his Wikipedia article for
four months has said that he was
involved in the assassinations of JFK
and Robert Kennedy and he writes a
scathing op-ed in which and he was
actually very close to the candy family
he was a pallbearer at one at Robert
Kennedy's funeral and so he is deeply
troubled by this and to write this this
becomes news in and of itself college
professor to start talking about banning
wikipedia from classrooms things like
that I mean it gets sort of major
coverage and then so the final punch
comes in this sort of part of
wikipedia's timeline with Stephen
Colbert's wiki allottee segment which is
also where in his conservative character
character he sort of satirizes Wikipedia
and it's actually the at the one of the
the segment in which he says the phrase
reality has a liberal bias if you
remember that and then the counterpart
of the next thing after that is and
thank God we have Wikipedia so that we
can write what I know and my
conservative got to be true and you know
it's really funny and but then he's like
really goes deep and he starts to link
wikipedia to the mindset that you know
got the u.s. into the Iraq war and sort
of the systematic denial of climate
change in evolution and then he invites
his millions of viewers to go and add
false facts to Wikipedia which they do
and I remember at the time i was there
i've been an editor there since 2004 for
a dimension and I
remember the being that at the time and
it was devastating but not just for not
just because all the Colbert people came
and did really predictable vandalism
that could really be reverted with some
dino pretty stupid bots but it was more
sort of this attack to wikipedias
mission to wikipedias you know a lot of
people look up to Colbert and sort of
you know had that instead of took what
he said seriously about you know are we
you know with the fact that anyone can
edit anything you know we're letting
quality slip you know what do we do
about this and so there's also a lot of
internal milestones that happen as well
the encyclopedia is filling up half a
million articles by 2005 1 million
articles by 2006 wikipedians start to
get very organized among themselves as
well there's a whole bunch of local
meetups that happen but the first global
Wiccan mania conference happens and sort
of this state of the community you know
what are we going to do about this
growing encyclopedia community the
foundation the wikimedia foundation
officially incorporates as a non-profit
they start to hire staff they do a
fundraiser and there's more and more
intense editorial controversies that are
taking place all across the encyclopedia
as pretty much every political and
ideological conflict on the planet earth
gets transported into wikipedia as
people start to argue about everything
from you know Israel and Palestine to
evolution and creationism to a
particular stat about the spelling of
the town in in Poland gdansk poland is
actually a particularly nasty issue that
sort of took a whole bunch of people's
time for years even though it's not sort
of a large-scale conflict outside of
wikipedia so just an anecdote from this
this is jimmy wales the co founder of
wikipedia and for a long time its
benevolent dictator and when he decides
that the global Wicca mania conference
to talk about something to everyone
there he talks about identifying and
eliminating trolls you know he holds
court about going into defense mode
about emphasizing quality over quantity
emphasizing the relationship that
wikipedia has to know to truth and to
reliability and to accuracy and so what
happens is that wikipedia starts to
formalize they do this in three
particular ways that are all linked to
each other first there's increased rules
policies and bureaucracy and this plays
out especially for biographies of living
people where you are able to sort of
then have a very standardized and quick
set of things and what you're able to
tell peep
that they are not allowed to edit a
particular article if article protection
starts to come in in in in force where
people can lock down pages and a new
bureaucracy that takes place to sort of
resolve the same kinds of issues that
are coming in again and again and again
and to also ban a lot of the Vandals and
a lot of the spammers and all the people
who are now editing Wikipedia in bad
faith because of its extreme popularity
and it's sort of the great link value
that it has as well so with increased
rules policies and bureaucracy come to
the ability to automate and oh and
standardize a lot of these processes and
so what happened as well as a lot of
tools came in fully automated BOTS and
also semi-automated like browser
extensions and things like this that
were used for doing a lot of that
quality control work and community
management work and i want to emphasize
these were really important tools that
had to be basically developed to keep
wikipedia at a level of quality that it
now that it now has this also then came
begin combined with the new attitude
towards newcomers which is sort of the
downside of this of this sort of phase
of wikipedia's history there was a
perception among veteran Wikipedians
that newcomers were basically not as
good as they used to be there was a
perception among these the people who
were spending hours and hours of their
time of their free time contributing to
this project that the people who were
coming in you know really you know
that's not something you know they're
there they're here basically to mess
things up they don't know what rules
they don't care about truth they don't
care that you know all these sort of
things they're just and so we need to
take action against them and so all of
these policies and guidelines and sort
of things that start to develop you
really have the effect of gatekeeping
Wikipedia this is the list of policies
in Wikipedia and actually I'm going to
zoom out I put these on my giant 4k
monitor and rotated them this is the
list of policy is just the list with a
one sentence description of each of them
with the policies list of guidelines in
the middle and the distinction between
policies and guidelines is really
important if you're a Wikipedian it
would take more than the length of this
talk to fully explain the nuances and
then this is the text of just one policy
as well on the right the amount that you
need to know to become an average
wikipedia editor that doesn't get their
contributions reverted or whenever it
someone decides to take issue with them
goes from scanning over the rules to
consider in 2001 to a text
that you need to be taught by an expert
that you can that's even really
difficult for you to read yourself in
2008 there's also as I said before these
automated tools this is one called
huggle that is really a brilliant piece
of technology and it comes it basically
put gives you in a queue edits and it
gives you a diff before and after and
you say is it good is it bad or I don't
know and if you say it's bad it has its
own algorithmic sort of process for
going through and automatically
determining what level of severity it is
and to automatically send a pre-written
templated message to the person telling
them not to do that in the what it
determines to be the appropriate tone
and voice so when we talk to the
wikipedians and we sort of gave these
statistics back and we said look you
know we've survival is at an all-time
low it's dropping and contributors are
dropping one of the things that we got
in response was you know well isn't this
kind of a good thing most of the people
who I see most of the people who I
interact with these tools are kind of
the worst of the worst and you know do I
really want people to survive if all
they're doing is adding the word poop
5,000 times to the article on you know
evolution or something like that so you
know basically aren't in today's
newcomers just worse than they were back
in the good old days and so we did some
research about this we had a project
that in the very large project that
involved both academic researchers and
wikipedians to manually hand code and
classify the contributions of newcomers
from 2003 to 2011 using wikipedias
established 2011 policies and we had
actually really good inter coder
inter-rater reliability among sort of
our reviewers for that and we found
there was actually not really a
significant measurable difference from
2004 2011 and the average level of
quality they're simply the average has
not changed the advert hasn't changed
but there's simply so many more people
that there's so many more people that
you have to deal with and that's where
one of these perceptions comes from
another perception that comes from also
the fact that a lot of the tools that
are built in Wikipedia are built to that
are built to support work our show you
the worst of the worst and they asked to
do something about it they don't show
you the best of the best they don't even
show you the mid-level people who maybe
need some help
so just some research on that to show
you there's of some some work it was
dumb of my collaborators and I about
this the proportion of good faith
newcomers who were reverted people whose
contributions were rated by Wikipedians
who didn't know when they were made or
who made them as either completely good
to revert them would be an act of
vandalism in itself or good faith and
that they needed some sort of
refactoring but they made a contribution
things that should not have been
immediately undead and what we see is
that you know starting in two thousand
starting in sort of mid-2006 to 2007 the
rate at which good faith valuable
contributors that you want in the
community starts to starts to rise so
people goes from about less than ten
percent of good good newcomers get
reverted to their first time to twenty
to thirty percent of newcomers that are
good faith get reverted their first time
and this also correlates highly with
retention as well so this is one of the
things we show for that previous plot it
included all the Vandals all the
spammers all the 12 year old kids adding
poop women so we filtered it out we
filtered out all those people and said
if we just have the people who are
making good contributions to the
community and we look at that retention
rate we see that also drops dramatically
as well from thirty to forty percent
retention down to as i said in 2011 it
was less than about it was about five
percent retention of people who sort of
good contributors you make good
contributions on their first their first
edit i mentioned before as well the role
of automated tools like huggle that send
messages to people upon being rejected
and this is a plot of the first messages
sent to new users it's a proportional
plot and the area in grey at the top are
messages that are sent by a human
opening up page typing a message and
sending it to another human everything
else in color is a different fully
automated bot or semi automated tool
that is used to automatically send
pre-written messages to people who have
men and by design only the tool in
yellow that then turns to dark green is
a tool that is used to tell people that
they are doing a good job everything
else in this everything else in this
this graph is a tool that is built to
tell you that you have done a poor job
and a lot of them the ones sorry the
ones in red and blue are built to tell
you that not only heavy
on a bad job if you continue to do this
you're going to be blocked from from
from at being able to edit Wikipedia
your IP address will be blocked and your
user account we will be banned so one of
the things that we did one of the first
things we did when we sort of found this
research or if we started to say well we
can't change a lot of these may be in
sort of design features as well but we
can av-test new messages and this is
actually one of the more benign messages
that got sent but you can read at the
very well maybe you might not be able to
make it out at the top for everyone but
the top was the original that was
written in a very passive and
institutional voice you know although
everyone is welcome to contribute to
Wikipedia you know one of your edits has
been reverted because it appears to be
unconstructive you know if you believe
the Edit was constructive ensure that
you provide an informative edit summary
so basically blaming the user for their
contribution being rejected as I should
before we're at the point where about
thirty percent of newcomers who make
good contributions are having their
contributions rejected in this way and
so we sort of did a whole bunch of
changes with us when we tested a lot of
versions and you know one like hello and
welcome I edit Wikipedia to under this
user name and these are messages in
order letter sent by a person not by
fully automated bot so we made it so
that if you revert someone you actually
have to put your user name in there and
tell people things like Wikipedia is
written by people like you and me thanks
for participating yeah i've reverted
your edit because it didn't appear
constructive to me if you think i've
made a mistake you know here's how to
ask me questions and some one of the
things that we were concerned about was
you know we wanted this to increase
retention and editor activity for the
good for the good people but we also
didn't want to encourage the Vandals and
the spammers and the 12 year old kids
who are adding nonsense and one of the
really great things about this
particular experiment is that we found
that both of those outcome metrics were
positive and that so not only did this
help this friendlier message help people
who were good making good contributions
stay longer even though they were
reverted if we also found that for the
people who are making really nasty
contributions it made them go away
faster so being nice to people who have
just done something really terrible
actually in this case was that well you
know we made them maybe possibly think
about what they had done especially
adding things like thank you for your
contribution but I didn't think it was
constructive it's an interesting
psychological thing to think
so some of the lessons there were there
are hundreds of pre-written templates
that are used in Wikipedia to manage
because that's the only way that you can
sort of do a lot of this work at scale
given that there are so many people
entering Wikipedia every day and be a
relatively small number of people who
are sort of core contributors to the
project I didn't I haven't included this
slide on that but I'll mention that that
about 4,500 people or one-tenth of one
percent of Wikipedia contributors are
responsible for about half the edits
that are made to the project yeah and
this skew is something that's sort of
very similar in seeing that a lot of
volunteer and peer production based
things I imagine open source is some
similar in that regard to and so we what
we did is we shouldn't say we actually
was only a part of the first sort of set
of experiments but then there was a
whole bunch of projects that were done
to test dozens and dozens and dozens of
automated messages so just some broad
lessons that were learned from from from
this to give if you're thinking about
doing a be testing as well one thing is
you need to sort of have some humility
because many times a message that we all
thought was going to be great had no
measurable effect you know it's science
you've got to sort of be prepared for be
prepared for that as well one thing is
interesting is a lot of messages that we
saw that did have effects only worked
for more experienced newcomers people
who would sort of made five to ten
previous edits at least since this is
some time thinking about you know
exactly where to target them we did some
things that we're working for people who
were above one particular hump but for
some reason you know not really not
really working for other people who were
sort of very very excuse me very very
newcomers to the project but also I
really want to encourage this sort of
model as well because it was a great way
to get volunteer contributors to
Wikipedia volunteer editors academic
researchers and wikimedia foundation
staff together all working on a quelle
on the same project a volunteer might
say hey I've got this template and I'm
thinking of doing something we said up
there was this whole infrastructure that
we set up for the first experiments that
we can use for dozens and dozens of
other experiments as well to do would
sort of to really make the work of a/b
testing streamlined and efficient and so
that's something that you should so I
would HIGHLY encourage if you've got
anything that you're sending that's
automated to people or any sort of text
that you're using do some may be testing
it sort of can really really help you
you're in the project another initiative
that I want to talk about is the tea
house since the project spearheaded by a
lot of people including jonathan morgan
who is one of my collaborators on the
previous sort of rise and decline sort
of work that i mentioned earlier and the
tea house was was built to be a very
different kind of place in wikipedia
where people could wear it involved
recruiting a whole bunch of veteran
Wikipedians who would serve as hosts and
would dedicate time to go to this
particular space and then having a place
where newcomers could come in and with a
very different user experience with
something that you didn't even have to
know wiki markup to be able to do you
could click a button have a window pop
up type of question end and someone
would be able to give you an answer very
quickly so it took a lot of work to sort
of set this up over the over you know
over a number of years but a lot of
there was a lot of the things a lot of
the results in the outcome metrics for
this has been very positive about it
providing a very nice space for
newcomers to be able to ask questions
whenever they get tripped up because not
everything can be found in a manual and
it's doodle rebound that Wikipedia is
existing help manuals really weren't
really weren't well well targeted for
the questions at newcomers we're having
so one thing is that they have a bot
that comes and invites newcomers who
have recently made their first 10 plus
edits they don't invite everyone because
they can't handle the capacity to have
all newcomers in Wikipedia there yet and
they get about a four point five percent
participate participation rate from
bought invites so that's not huge but
it's still you know more more than
nothing and that's about actually the
level that they can sustain with the
current number of hosts that they have
they did some also some some controlled
experiments as well this one was done in
2015 where they had newcomers who they
either they had a sort of population of
newcomers who made at least 10 edits in
their first 24 hours or at least 20
edits in their first four days they
either didn't give them an invite and
then they then they gave they had seen
through people who they gave an invite
to but they didn't choose to participate
then they had a bucket of people who
they invited and they did participate
and you can see that there's also these
are sort of some of the descriptive
statistics I'm also told that there's
some more rigorous sort of survival Matt
I survival analysis that is also
confirmed that these are statistically
significant results as well but we can
see like even things like the number of
reach
you know editors that are active one
month after this goes out you know goes
from you know nine percent of it people
who don't get the message eleven percent
for people who do get the message I
don't think those two are statistically
significant from each other but then
thirty-three percent of people who
participate in the teahouse are people
who stay in Wikipedia as well so
changing that metric from the sort of
ten percent that we saw we've seen
throughout the literature to
thirty-three percent that's that's a big
deal so also they make more edits they
make more debts as well about twice as
much of the people who get the invite
and but and they're blocked it basically
the statistically insignificant rate
that was another thing that wikipedians
want to make sure of is that we're not
encouraging people who then go on to
basically learn the skills to disrupt
the Encyclopedia so that as well also
there was a survey that was done with
overall satisfaction and both newcomers
and veterans day they were either
satisfied or very satisfied with their
experience and then a final thing that I
want to point out is that in this survey
of this about twenty eight percent of
the newcomer respondents were women
which is versus about eight to thirteen
percent of all wikipedia editors or
women as well and so this has been a
space in which a lot of the people who
are very passionately working in
Wikipedia on issues of representation
diversity and inclusion have been
working very closely with the tea house
to try to make this into a space where
sort of people from marginalized groups
can come and to hopefully sort of remove
some of those sort of long-term
long-term barriers and so with that I'm
going to segue into the talking about
issues of diversity inclusion and
representativeness and I'm going to
share with you some statistics as well
from this one thing is that this is one
thing that about the gender gap i said
before eight to thirteen percent
depending on how you measure it but this
is a paper that get that graft the
cutting number the percentage of female
editors over by the number of edits that
they had made and so what this shows is
that that that it's sort of a it's a
pipeline problem not in the sense of
there's a previous sort of set of things
that you know that that editors that
women need to have they're not getting
from the educational system as is often
discussed with that with with the
industry but the pipeline of Wikipedia
socialization itself is systematically
just under rep
presenting women so about twenty percent
of people of editors who come in who
only have one edit our women and when we
get to sort of the higher ranks by the
time you get to 512 that's at about
seven percent as well there's also an
interesting bump though when you get to
the very very highly active editors is a
small bump I'm not sure if that's a
statistically significant difference but
it shows that this is that sort of
gender gotten Wikipedia is definitely an
issue of the socialization process and
the retention process there's something
going on there this is also from the
same paper that was done I got the
citation below as well if you're
interested reading the whole thing
they've got a lot of work the rates at
which female editors are reverted as
well is as is statistically significant
at the lower rates as well and so this
is one of the things as well that is
predicted that is that women
contributors are getting reverted more
often than than men are in Wikipedia
especially at they're at their lower
levels so another thing another great
sort of piece that of that I highly
encourage you to read is a piece by sue
gardner who is the executive director of
the wikimedia foundation and she has
this piece where she did a lot of
interviews with women who both
contributed to wikipedia formerly
contribute to wikipedia or had never
added a wikipedia at all about why women
don't edit wikipedia and she has nine
reasons including some of them are
technical things like it's a difficult
user interface interface so I'm in there
things that are sort of that go beyond
sort of Wikipedia specific aspect that
are sort of universal to society things
like not having enough free time this is
something that you know labor and
volunteer hours and any volunteer
community is going to be systematically
underrepresented in this aspect and
that's something that's a broader
systemic issue that also needs to be
dealt with as well then also things like
a version to conflict things like
finding the overall atmosphere
misogynistic and now finding that their
contributions aren't perceived as valued
as well there's also a whole bunch of
research as well on measuring the
representation of various topics in
Wikipedia and even the rates at which
articles about you know biographies
about women get deleted at higher rates
than then the Bayern biography is about
men as well so that's that's another
thing that this is focused on and I'll
add some I have some links to a lot of
as research as well so one of the things
that's been done to try to sort of solve
attack all these issues both with both
with the gender gap and also there's a
whole bunch of gaps as well with with
race and ethnicity and income that's one
of the also one of the things that that
demographic demographic surveys of the
Wikipedia community has shown that it is
predominantly edited by by men who are
of the age of sort of 20 to about 20 to
35 who sort of grow up in in sort of
Anglophone countries as well so this is
so edita ponds that have been targeted
to specific demographic groups that have
been underrepresented have been growing
substantially over the past years this
is from a sort of wiki women's Women's
History Month thong that was done at the
wikimedia foundation just a few blocks
away from here and one of the things
about edita fonz and community outreach
projects that the people who have been
you know doing a lot of this work have
been talking about this is sort of a mix
of veterans and newcomers is really
needed you have to do high recruitment
work on both of those aspects as well
you can't sort of expect a lot of people
to simply com it takes you know takes a
lot of initiative to do that you need to
be able to teach the necessary tech
skills and the jargon to participate in
Wikipedia but sort of as a reference
before like one day really isn't enough
I mean I've heard some people sort of
say that it would take for almost the
equivalent of an entire University for
unit class over the course of a semester
to really get you to the point that you
know everything about how to interact
with wikipedians as veteran wikipedians
do so this is something that's sort of
been people have been really thinking
about as well there's also a whole bunch
of new initiatives for doing sort of
long-term community engagement some are
actually working with you people and
university courses as well particularly
in like for example Women and Gender
Studies classes and then finally I have
this third but it should be laughs
there's there's a great evaluations in
metrics infrastructure that they're
spinning up to try to try to decide and
I identify and decide what kinds of
tactics and strategies and different
recruiting aspects are more successful
and less successful for that and so the
link of that is at at that so oh so
there's also I have a whole bunch of
leaks in this slide 24 different sort of
organization in groups that are really
doing fantastic work on this and I if
you're interested in is you I highly
encourage you to check out
the project on countering system it by
asst the gender gap task force the wiki
Education Foundation and then the
wikimedia foundation also is starting to
provide individual engagement grants for
people who have a particular idea about
how they want to tackle these issues may
the allocated funds for that as well so
I want to conclude by just sort of
talking about referencing some of the
things that I haven't been able to get
to in this project but I think are
really interesting efforts and projects
around community sustainability one or
streamlined and simplified guides to
policy because that is a the policy is
in the environment is incredibly complex
and very difficult to navigate finally
like a draft article space with lacks or
rules so that people don't have to be
able to have their articles immediately
subjected to review criticism and
potentially deletion whenever they
create a new article changing the user
interface and a lot of different ways in
particular one so that newcomers can
signal good faith intent to veteran bad
veteran veterans who often will the
often will sort of delete articles or
revert contributions within a minute of
them being made and there's also some
semi automated tools there's one called
that go beyond quality control as I'd
mentioned before the quality control
tool show you the worst of the worst and
there's a tool called snuggle that was
built by my collaborator Aaron half
occur to that is a play on the huggle
tool that I showed you earlier that it
shows you sort of people who are really
in need of help and it's built to
connect mentors and mentees there's also
a whole bunch of user interface sort of
things about how newcomers can take on
more lopez task like article feedback
but trying to do that in a way that is
sort of Metro sized and actually does
make make it work and doesn't increase
the amount of work for four people a
really interesting project also by Aaron
Aaron have occurred about sort of
co-created machine learning projects
getting community members involved in
developing the algorithmic systems that
gate keep Wikipedia and sort of police
for spam and vandalism because a lot of
those also have some issues with them as
well and also a mentioned sort of
long-term qualitative studies of
contributors especially those in
marginalized groups is taking place
there's a number of academics who are
who are researching this right now and
if you were interesting that i can
definitely connect you with that so with
that I think my time is up and I'm open
for questions and thank you very much
for listening
you